always love we all have stuff that
pisses us off the more successful the
powerful we are the more there will be
that we think we need to protect in
terms of our legacy image and influence
if we're not careful however we can end
up wasting an incredible amount of time
trying to keep the world from
displeasing or disrespecting us you know
what is a better response to an attack
or a slight of someone you don't like
love that's right love for the neighbor
who won't turn down the music for the
parent that let you down for the
bureaucrat who lost your paperwork for
the group that rejects you for the
credit who attacks you the former
partner who stole your business idea the
person who cheated on you love because
as a song lyrics go hate will get you
every time it doesn't need to be like
that booker t washington tells an
anecdote told to him by frederick
douglass about a time who was traveling
and was asked to move and ride in the
baggage car because of his race a white
supporter rushed up to apologize for
this horrible offense i am sorry mr.
Douglas that you have been degraded in
this manner the person said Douglas
would have none of that he wasn't angry
he wasn't hurt he replied with great
fervor they cannot degrade Frederick
Douglass the soul that is within me no
man can degrade I am not the one that is
being degraded on account of this
treatment but those who are inflicting
it upon me certainly this is an
incredibly difficult attitude to
maintain it's easy to hate it's natural
to lash out yet we find that what
defines great leaders like Douglas is
that instead of hating their enemies
they feel a sort of pity and empathy for
them think of Martin Luther King jr.
over and over again preaching that hate
was a burden and love was freedom love
was transformational hate was
debilitating and one of his most famous
sermons he took it further we begin to
love our enemies and love those persons
that hate us whether in collective life
or individual life by looking at
ourselves we must strip ourselves of the
ego that protects and suffocates us
because as he said hate at any point is
a cancer that gnaws away at the very
vital center of your life and your
existence it is like eroding acid that
eats away the best and the objective
center of your life take inventory for a
second what do you dislike
whose name feels you with revulsion and
range now ask have these strong feelings
really helped you accomplish anything
especially because almost universally
the traits and behaviors that are pissed
us off and other people their dishonesty
their selfishness their laziness are
hardly going to work out well for them
in the end their ego and
shortsightedness contains its own
punishment the question we must ask
ourselves is are we going to be
miserable just because other people are
this obsession with the past was
something that someone did or how things
should have been as much as it hurts is
ego and body everyone else has moved on
but you can't because you can't see
anything but your own way you can't
conceive of accepting that someone could
hurt you deliberately or otherwise so
you hate when it would be so much better
to love in failure or adversity it's so
easy to hate hate the first bling it
makes someone else responsible it's a
distraction to we don't have to feel our
feelings when we're busy getting revenge
or investigating the wrongs that have
supposedly been done to us does this get
us any closer to where we want to be no
it just keeps us where we are or worse
arrests our development entirely
meanwhile love is right there eagle is
open positive vulnerable peaceful and
productive always love
you